chatting exciting news magic mike is
back
yeah it's gonna be uh i mean i don't
know we're coming to london by the way
um so it's gonna be set in london and uh
wow i don't i don't really know what to
say other than you know i didn't i
wasn't really planning on doing a third
one and then we went and made these live
shows and what we learned on the live
show is really
you know we we had some of the like most
premier sickest answers that you could
possibly find in the world uh performing
and and then what we learned along the
way around men and women in this sort of
space is uh it's really really fun stuff
and so we decided to make a make a third
movie and i was like look two two uh two
goals and the i'd say the first goal was
to i want to make like the super bowl of
stripper movies
uh i wanted just to like have just leave
it all out there like i want to have
like
ballet stripping i want to do it all
like so they're just there doesn't ever
need to be another like
stripper movie ever again and second i
wanted a really strong equal uh like
female role
wow and are you in rehearsals right now
yes they casted it if you ask if he's
got the cast yet
just
no we're still casting what's up kyle i
live london rob if he can hear me yeah
he can hear you
[Applause]
can hear me
got any good parts mate i can i can limp
on the command
it's probably quite good for a stripper
actually though
i feel like johannes could be in it
because if you studied magic mike well i
was never allowed to
i said that because i look i'm looking
at him now and i'm just thinking you
know
how how are there to hide
because i visited him so much no i think
i think cheney was
yay
[Laughter]
may i ask humpty yes please do dawg
hello tanning chatum i'm dawn fred
hello you wouldn't know me i'm from the
80s and i'm a goer
oh thank you um i just wanna say after
these last couple of years that we've
had where we've all been locked in it's
been so dim and
grim um do you feel like you should take
more risks and maybe be a bit more
spontaneous and just say yes to things
in life without even really thinking
about it like if i asked you something
now would you say yes dawn i will
[Applause]
i i you know i feel like i'm walking
into something here but uh but yes dawn
i will you're a goer let's go
well i have to tell you then tani chatum
that you
just agreed to marry my daughter
[Applause]
and he's flying himself in
you know
be real convenient
[Music]
you